[Music]
thank you
one week later so that this will
probably come out after the fight so can
you discuss strategy or do you have like
specific strategies for how to beat her
yes so this is actually very funny
um we're sure this is coming yes
you won't have time unless you guys want
us to lick anything
um one funny thing so I have been doing
a little bit of Chess prep with my coach
Hammer
um and so I find out the color day
before and then I was the white openings
I was doing on my own and I have a good
friend who's very good at the London
Eric Rosen and I remember looking at
Dina's lines it was a line that Eric
showed me and I forgot and I messaged
him just asking for like one or three
moves and he was so nice he made an
entire video he screen recorded a 20
minute video explaining he made a chess
based file so hopefully if I end up
getting the white pieces I want Eric
Rosen to post his video because it was
the nicest thing anyone's ever done all
right so I'm gonna go ahead and share
that secret video I I made for Andrea
botes and I really hope this goes to
show the type of work it takes to
prepare for a high level chess match and
then in the future video I will be
breaking down the game that actually
played so stay tuned for that and big
thanks to Andrea for giving me
permission to leak the secret video to
the world okay so I just made a file for
Andrea
on some London prep against Dina for
this upcoming chess boxing match
and I thought it would make sense just
to go through the file and I'll probably
explain things in this video as if I was
just explaining it to Andrea because
she's the main like target audience
audience of one so let me open the file
and I'll just share my Approach
I tried to keep it concise
but there is I mean there's always more
to add but I tried to give at least kind
of the the must-nos and share some of
the uh the really nice landmines that uh
Gina could potentially walk into and I
actually started with a site called
opening tree
um you can use chess.com Explorer uh
just to sift through Dina's online games
and
and um basically what it does it brings
in all her black games I went through
the steps to just select username color
and then I checked to see
what she plays against London
and she's mixed it up at least on
chess.com
now you should probably check
her over the board games too I haven't
done that yet uh maybe I can do that
afterwards just to be a bit more
thorough but it's pretty clear she's
going for C5 and uh and Knight F6 most
often usually these lines will transpose
there are cases where black play C5
employees Knight C6 for a while but um
I really just based the file off of
Knight F6 kind of the main London move
order
um so there are transpositions but the
key position is after Knight F3 which I
recommend starting with Knight C6 Knight
T2
uh she plays Bishop G4 most often she's
also played CD4
we should also include Bishop F5 I
didn't realize she's played this three
times
um against Bishop about five you should
take and then play Knight D4
and this offer is like a nice position
for whites I'd be surprised if she
enters that uh in this chess boxing
match
but uh just to show real quick Bishop by
five
and large the window
uh take E6 Knight T4 it's a very nice
line uh point being that
white threatening this and Bishop to B5
and black should take but that allows
takes takes and white has better
structure along with the bishop pair
along with some initiative you can
Castle play C3 Knight B3 Queen F3 Rook
D1 and just had a really stable position
uh usually play against isolate Queen's
Pawn
so let's go back
uh what I wanted to focus on
it seems like Andrea already
discover this is Dina playing Bishop G4
hence the Discord message asking uh
about our lesson from a while ago where
I showed some lines in this variation it
was mainly just a nice trappy line but
the preparation goes beyond that
uh so let's say Bishop G4
uh C3 and E6 and then Queen A4 so this
is one of the main positions where
things can Branch out
and it was a good sign going back to
opening tree
after
Queen A4 Dina's reached this position in
three times in online play
and
in every single game she's made like a
clear blunder basically Bishop D6 and
queen C8 are both pretty much losing on
the spot
and then the one game she played Bishop
takes off three she followed up with
Bishop D6 which also loses on the spot
so let's hop into the file and I'll just
show the the key lines
um first of all we'll start with Queen
C8 which I don't expect her to repeat
but it's good to at least understand
what the ideas are here uh White very
simply plays Knight E5
and now there's two threats there's
Bishop B5 and F3 and there's not really
a great way of stopping both threats an
online game she played she went for A6
but then after F3
Bishop H5 G4 Bishop G6 H4
this is not just a way of getting
Initiative for white this is a way of
guaranteeing like a permanent advantage
on the king side the problem for black
is H5 is coming the only way to save the
bishop is to move the H Pawn and then
Knight takes G6 will be played so for
example H6 takes takes and then I mean
this is just uh very very nice for white
so this is nothing to worry about
um Queen C8 would be uh
very welcome move
and then of course the like the choppy
lines Bishop F3 Knight F3 Bishop D6 runs
into Bishop A6 and all the tactics work
for white if Bishop F4
take on B7 and black is losing material
um now I should note that
there's a way to play this for black in
this position
that
pretty close to equalizes I should
include this in the file
um let me just see
actually the approach I'll take
generally what I like to do is
just open analysis on the chess and then
check the the chest database because
that will give the most played moves so
it's funny Bishop A6 is the most played
move uh but it's just a very big plunder
as long as you know Bishop A6 most
people do
second most played as A6 and Knight D7
so those would probably be the more
likely options to expect
um if A6 in this position
yeah engine
just disconnect here
so the engine's giving
close to equal maybe a slight Edge for
white
um you can't quite get the same like 95
Bishop B5 pressure 95 I see it's still a
move
um this might take some dinging for me
to explore
[Music]
what the the best option would be I'm
actually wondering why not Bishop D3
engine doesn't like C4 yet that can be
annoying
so A6
so what if 95
because black can't play B5 immediately
because Knight takes C6 should be good
for white so let's say Rook C8
is there some some tactic Knight C6 and
Bishop A6
oh
yeah okay because
because uh black has to really jump
through some hoops here
to survive I'd recommend 95.
because if black plays Rook C8 then
black has to find
Queen D7 which isn't the most
natural move to play it does bring back
the piece the problem with Rook C6
to show make this a main line is Bishop
A6 really nice tactics Rooks pinned and
the pawn is uh just overworked
so
you have Queen D7 yeah White's still
really solid just get back the knights
engine likes Bishop E5
engine wants to trade on F6 eventually
this is where I pause and just kind of
look at uh some of the engine moves and
try and see what's like practically the
uh the choice to go for
Bishop D3 is a move
and Bishop E5 is actually very concrete
I think the strategy is just to get a a
really solid position where you can kind
of grind the game for a while and not be
at risk of losing early on
I mean I'm not so familiar with the
boxing portion but I assume
it's to Andrea's favor
to have a longer chess game because
she's not so much the um
like Dina is much higher rated
so oh I see uh Andrea just responded
uh
I'll probably just respond with a whole
recording of the video once I finish
this I I want to try and be thorough so
um if Queen D7
also want to not be not make this too
long I say I'm already nine minutes and
um
let's just explore this bishop E5
this is really the type of work Andreas
should do on her own too like after I
give her uh this file like it's good to
expand on some of these lines I'd also
recommend like play some training games
from
maybe even a position like this and just
get a feel for how to play beyond the
opening so let's look Rook take C6
Bishop takes F6 gf6 and
I like G3 G3 is such a funny move but
because the G file is open White's going
to be really safe with the structure
and
yeah maybe like later E4
it seems like a good strategy for a
chess boxing match like just you're not
going to lose in the next like 30 or 40
moves I would hope
so anyway um let's go back
I didn't want to go on too much of a
tangent but just be aware that um I mean
black very close to equalize if they
don't fall for the traps uh Knight D7 is
another move which I didn't include uh
but here I think Bishop B5
yeah episode B5
Queen B6 is natural
[Music]
and C4 is a very common idea
if it works immediately
probably be one of my go-to choices
because you have the bishop pair it's
nice to pressure the center open things
up
um A6 is a move but it doesn't actually
threaten the bishop
and now castling
yeah it's definitely a black who's under
a bit of pressure here and you can leave
tension for a bit maybe like take
eventually and Retreat the bishop you
can see an example line Bishop E7
ah light's going to take on C6 so okay
wait for back to Castle now the rook's
defended now we take take take take
and
yeah try and use the C file
very calm move Rook Rook C2 or Rook C3
probably prefer Rook C2
just preparing the double up
anyway
um
I'm really making this video to get some
like main points across about just the
the overall opening approach in general
the other line I wanted to point out is
okay after Queen A4 of course the same
trap exists like Bishop D6 Bishop A6
and
if black doesn't fall for the Trap
Knight D7 is like a logical looking move
to diffuse the diagonal but here and
okay you can see my comments
um I make this bigger turn off the
engine
uh here white can play Bishop B5 and
just keep exerting pressure
I played this position a good number of
times online most common move I
encounter is Queen B6 and then still 95.
there's actually a really nice line here
that kind of requires
memorization
um is after black takes and we should
note this is basically the only move
black has because White's threatening
the bishop and the Knights
um and taking taking with other Knight
doesn't work as as well
um I think for obvious reasons so
Knight D takes is expected and then then
there's a really cool in-between move
Pawn takes Pawn
and the point of this is we're
guaranteeing the fourth rank to open and
okay of course we're hitting the queen
so after Bishop takes C5 we take the
Knight and we're still threatening the
bishop
we're actually threatening to take the
Knight first and then take the bishop
but G7 is also attacked
and this position has been reached in a
handful of online games most players
will play Bishop F5 or Bishop H5 and now
here
you don't take on G7 immediately because
Rook Gia gets counter play But first you
play G4 supported by the queen
if Bishop takes G4 then we take it's
important to take first and then um
whatever it takes you in the bishop
G4 essentially forces Bishop G6 and then
you take and then just go back basically
forcing traded Bishops whites up a clean
Pawn here you have committed to G4 but
um the engine will give like over plus
one for whites
so that's one of the nice lines that I
think it's important to know and
especially if you're playing Blitz you
you want to just slow down a little bit
to make sure you remember the the move
order to take the pawn first and then
take the knights
um there's other branches but
again I wanted to show just like the
the key variations and
uh I mean generally Bishop B5 95 C4
these are the main resources uh there
there could be a lot of other branches
uh that can happen from this position
and it's hard to prepare against
everything but
um it's good to know the basic plans for
whites
the other line I wanted to briefly touch
on and then I'll I'll end the video but
um other line is he takes D4 which I'd
seen
Dina play
let's see let's just go back to the tree
if we go back a little bit further we
can see she's played it three times in
this position
C takes D4 is also playable in this
position she's also played it in this
position so it's just one of those lines
that can kind of transpose from a bunch
of different move orders and it's really
important to distinguish between
the early trade on D4
and the line where there's still Pawn
tension you're able to go for Queen A4
so in this line
there's completely different plans for
white whites no longer going for Queen
A4 because of the fourth ranks close and
there's not the same ideas of like
opening a fourth rank C3 Queen A4 just
doesn't work in the same way it does
another line
so here I recommend a very solid
positional approach
starting with C3 just defend D4 E6
and then the mainline's queen B3 the
move I'm recommending is Bishop D3
which I think is just a lot more
straightforward
um just aiming to complete kingside
development most players play Bishop D6
after takes takes
uh Castle
[Music]
Castle there's been a lot of games
played from this position uh I recommend
throwing in H3 uh usually a useful move
to throw in slight Improvement and then
rookie one is the most flexible move
and the goal in this position is just to
be really really solid and to employ
some gradual improvements most players
play A6 here going for the minority
attack and then white has a very similar
response Pawn to A4 not only preventing
B5
but creating a scenario where maybe in
the future white wants to play A5 B4
Knight B3 Knight C5
and gather really nice grip on
the queen side
and uh yeah I've been so many Grand
Masters using this idea
um it can come from different boarders
like there's lines where the bishop goes
to F5 rather than G4 but
um if if white can get the pawn to A5
and B4 and plant the Knight and C5 it's
a very powerful concept and like already
from this position it's not entirely
clear what Black's plan is
I was analyzing Queen F4 earlier
but yeah that's like kind of a random
move I think the most played move is
Rook C8
and then
I mean engine will generally give
plus equals
engine saying Queen B1
honestly A5 A5 would be my choice it's
one of the top or was one of the top
moves but I think it's uh the simplest
move to understand
and um again it would help to play out
some like training games from this
position maybe in the blitz format where
you go for uh for these ideas like for
example Queen C7 hitting the pawn white
plays B4
if the Knight moves I assume Rook C1
first and then the Knight has a clear
path
so
okay I didn't want to make this video
too long we're still below the 20 minute
Mark uh good luck to Andrea
um I hope this if you did watch this I
hope it brings you some value if you
have questions before the match let me
know and take them down good luck